e
e e
okay good morning
everyone um and I hope everybody had a
successful day yesterday and and are all
happy
happy who yeah we Jane's the only one
not coming back
right okay so what we're going to do
today what uh the pending motions that
when we finally do exec these bills is
recommended or not recommended for
future
legislation they took away several years
ago uh the opportunity to um say
recommended with
Amendment which that then opened up the
opportunity for a lot of discussion and
a lot of you know detailed work and
stuff like that so um they don't have
that anymore uh that means that to
recommend for future legislation means
that the bill as written is it perfect
and ready for prime time which of course
that would be almost
impossible uh because we inter room
study it for a reason because it wasn't
ready for prime time uh so my
expectation is that everything is
eventually going to be interim study but
I want to use these two days or to uh
flush out things that people would like
to have a discussion on and that is I
want to treat it as though it was a
chapter study so that people can have
time to spend to work on that subject uh
those who are interested in and getting
and in passing that um and but knowing
in at the end it's going to be the the
final motion would be not recommended
but at least gives everybody an
opportunity because I when as you
remember when we um last this past year
when we talked about bills of being in
interim study them we were saying but
are we really going to study them so and
this is the moment where that is this is
where you have to say yes okay we really
do want to study it we really want to
think more about it and and you're
willing to come in another day and cut
out your campaign
time to come in here and want to work on
that issue because you care about the
issue and you think it's something
that's worth working on does that make
sense what do you think
um I know we can't reintroduce a bill
next if if you modify it enough can you
re put in a new bill it doesn't matter
you and in terms that's very good
question yeah everything is fair game
okay for next session okay okay words
you can you can you can introduce the
exact same language right as word for
word um obviously it will if the
conversation comes up with well did you
put this in last year and what was the
motion well it was not recommended by
this committee but you're that you know
we this committee cannot bind the makeup
of what this committe is going to look
like come January
yep okay everybody clear good all right
so what I'm going to do is to go over
the bills in which people have said they
want to um speak on so the first one I
have is HB
1117 relative to creating a committee to
study the protection of business
operators against a
request to accommodate customers with
fraudulent or untrained service
animals yes I remember this bill okay so
who would like to speak on you would
like to speak on it is
that yeah okay so um you're just so
everybody knows this is you're not
testifying you are just sharing with us
your feelings about this bill
thank you I'm uh Jerry Stringham the uh
representative uh from Lincoln and
Woodstock uh this this bill was
originally um uh forwarded to this
committee I was the uh Prime sponsor of
it the primary goal was to um uh help um
restaurant lodging and other businesses
in the area that are having a difficult
time
uh with misbranding of service animals
or or animals that uh aren't service
animals and creating havoc in some of
the uh
establishments uh as as we know in the
earlier testimony was that um uh that
we're pretty handcuffed on what new
regulations we can create by federal law
um there's um you know while you've been
studying it in this learned committee I
um a few things that I just want wanted
to share uh based on feedback that I've
gotten from local uh restaurants and uh
um uh hotels and campgrounds is that um
that what they thought would be helpful
would be um uh uh information that to
help facilitate a dialogue with somebody
who wants to use their facility and um
um there is there is one short form that
talks about that they can post and put
on their wall saying you know it's a
violation to Mis brand your dog and say
it's a service dog when it's not and
subject to a $500 fine that's gotten a
little bit of help in creating that um
uh but um more recently you know we
talked about just having a form they
said okay you want to bring a service
dog in um it doesn't seem like there's
any restriction in federal law to
prevent you from asking them to fill out
a form form that doesn't ask any
questions that um uh are prohibited by
federal law so um what I did was create
a sample Hospitality form um it might be
different you know this problem also
extends over to hospitals too by the way
and um um you know if there are if if
there aren't other recommendations what
I would suggest is that uh that there
just be a referral to the Department of
Agriculture who I believe is the entity
in charge of
of uh local laws that they create uh and
uh check in checkin forms that comply
with uh New Hampshire state and federal
service animal access requirements and
then report back uh to Commerce and
perhaps myself on whether any bills uh
would be uh needed or recommended uh to
be able to put forward some kind of uh
checklist like that so uh the front the
so that's that's uh I guess you know um
my activities outside of the inter room
study I guess that's that's as far as um
that I've been able to progress with it
and I just wanted to share that with the
committee and and if you thought it was
a good idea to make a referral I'd app I
I'm I would be supportive of
that great uh representative burrow has
a question thanks thanks for taking my
question um representative if a if a
restaurant or facility gave you this
form would it be a mandate that you sign
it that you fill this out before your
animal came
in um I guess I would ask for I I I
think it's reasonable to ask them to
sign it um but I mean would your law
mandate at and if not why do we need a
law to do
this right that that may be right and I
mean because a restaurant can just hand
this
out well I I do think it would be nice
if they're going to hand it out that at
least be that the state um make a uh uh
that the questions are reasonable and
comply with state and federal law but we
don't need a laot to for them to do that
it it it we that's true we might not
that's why you know I said in there that
uh uh report back whether legislation is
needed or not so if it's not required or
if they can't require it then maybe it
doesn't if it if they can require it
then maybe it does I don't know that
might be the answer representative Gibbs
thank you uh this is more a comment than
a question um because this was actually
part of my my field um as a civil rights
uh law enforcement officer uh both for
the state and then for the federal
government and I think it's problematic
to require um a person with a disability
to uh write down what service their uh
service animal performs and sign off on
it it is true that this uh to be a
service animal the the animal has to
perform a specific service it can't be
just an emotional support animal that's
quite correct um but it would not be
legal for instance to require a person
with a disability to write down what
their disability is and I think
similarly requiring the person with a
disability to write down and sign off on
what service the animal performs I think
that's problematic and I'm not not sure
that would be legal yeah um and you know
I'm not a lawyer but I I did know that
um uh pretty much the only thing they're
allowed to ask is what function yeah
what function does the service animal
provide for you and that's and virtually
every restaurant and hotel that I've
talked to about it understand that's
pretty much all they can ask and right
and that's Federal that's the federal so
regulations you tell us what the trick
is that the dog does
okay great and uh there's one other
person who wants to testify great so
awesome aot like volunteer a volunteer
thanks good morning morning I need oh
you you hit the button you got
it you like buttons on there we go can
you hear me
now okay my name is Bron Madden and I am
I live in D New Hampshire and i r
present the nonprofit organization
called the New Hampshire Coalition for
the support of service dogs and what we
do is we provide financial aid to people
with service dogs New Hampshire and also
another one of our focuses is on
education and advocacy and so I wanted
to be here today to share my thoughts
about this
bill
um my my dad brought some uh things to
hand out to you um I did some pretty
extensive research
um as as you can see there are already
pretty
stringent uh service doog laws in New
Hampshire and my question
is um do
businesses not know the two questions
they can ask
um which
are shoot let me find them
here
sorry not have
oh anyway I I know them um the uh is it
a service dog and what what tasks is it
trained to
perform and I think the the main
solution to this problem is um requiring
businesses to ask those questions and
also
um I'm not sure if the businesses know
that if the dog is Miss behaving at all
they can ask the dog to be
removed great thank you uh would you be
willing to take a question yeah
okay I was just thank you for for coming
and uh answering our questions I was
just curious about your organization
could you tell us about your your
organization for service dogs yes so my
organization provides financial aid to
people in theal with service dogs um uh
uh for example like if your service dog
needs like emergency surgery you can
apply to us for our grant to help with
that
yeah represent thank you I I have one
question um you said that we can ask
these two questions which is great cuz I
actually work um at an ice cream shop
and there's people always bringing their
dogs in and we're never sure how to deal
with this so this is really informative
to me personally um when people come in
with a service dog on it but then it's
some sort of an emotional support dog
what would what would be an approp roate
answer for them if I would ask what
they're trained to do cuz that seems
like that's not a service dog per se
that might be something different or
maybe you would know yeah that's not
serves dog okay so an emotional support
dog wouldn't need to be yes accepted
into an establishment so the difference
between service dogs and emotional SW
dogs is that um service dogs are covered
under the Ada and they have access
rights pretty much anywhere okay great
that's very help emotional Sheriff's
dogs don't okay great thank you so
much y uh thank you uh again thank you
for asking our questions just my
question is you are giving funds to
folks who have service dogs if they
request them uh what is the source of
your
funding um so recently we got a pretty
tangal GR Grant from the enhancer herit
Foundation but I I've done a lot of
things like um like uh craft fairs and
um uh restaurant
fundraisers and things little things
like
that great well thank you so much and we
appreciate you coming in and and uh
informing us on this important service
you guys provide thank you and and if
you have any more questions please feel
free to shoot me an
email yeah I just do would you okay I
just looked up because I was curious
what airlines do in terms of emotional
support Dr dogs and they're treated as
pets and they get to charge a fee to fly
with them and they're not obligated to
allow them on board so it seems like
that would
beable do you agree with
that and that's um the other thing was
service dogs it's
um um so
um so with with emotional support
animals it is an
individual uh Airline
decision representative
Gibbs thank you uh just for
clarification on the difference between
emotional support animals and service
animals um emotional support animals are
covered under the fair housing act so
they have to be allowed in apartments
but uh their emotional support animals
are not covered under the Ada so they
don't have to be allowed in restaurants
or on public transportation such as
Airlines or trains uh public
transportation and restaurants and
public accommodations only have to allow
service animals that are trained to do a
specific function
correct okay thank you
all right uh is there any more
discussion
on uh 11:17 everybody's got their handle
on that one all right next up uh
1395 excuse
yeah yeah we're not gonna we're not
voting
today we haven't scheduled it
yet
we um I'm assuming that there might be
some bills here that people are going to
want to spend some time with so we have
to allow them to do that and then we'll
come back
and EXA
every okay all right so the next one I
have is 1395 relative to home heating
oil and propane
contracts okay for bring Leslie Anderson
up with me uh absolutely thank
you so just so you know the the
prevailing motion or I said the
prevailing discussion is not recommended
for future legislation so you're going
to speak to why you think that's a good
idea I
am thank you Mr chairman so um Leslie
and I after the he why don't you
introduce yourself yes Robert Scully um
use the
microphone Robert Scully lobbyist for
Propane Gas Association of New England
and energy marketers Association New
Hampshire with me is Leslie Anderson the
president of propane gas Association of
New
England so we appear before you today um
after the hearing on houseb 1395 this
session if a brief reminder it was um in
our opinion put in because of a One Bad
Apple in the industry maras if you
remember right um and the poor customer
service associated with that company on
removing tanks and getting back to uh
customers so we work together to put
together a best practices which is being
distributed to you on how to deal with
customers that desire to move tanks have
complaints or have needs and issues um
to try to have them contact us as
opposed to and work with them as opposed
to maybe go to the Attorney General's
office and for us to provide assistance
which we believe that 99% of the small
deals in the state of New Hampshire
already do so um we're trying to make
this issue go away um working through
our two entities here and on the bottom
of this page you'll take a look at it we
provide our our numbers to contact and
call this is going out in our website
this our websites this is an industry
accepted practice on how to deal with
issues that people have with changing
companies or with tanks or problems with
propane or oil so um happy to answer any
questions in case there's a technical
one I didn't know I asked Leslie to come
um when we testified am meras was for
sale and we thought maybe they wouldn't
be operating in the state of New
Hampshire anymore but that sale fell
through so um put it right on the table
because that's what we thought was going
to happen before the state in front of
you now but it did not so um so there's
any questions on that I'll have you ask
Miss Anderson but um that's kind of a
quick summary of Where where why we
think this bill doesn't need to move
forward thank
you okay
yeah thank you uh with respect to the
fact that air gas has not been sold are
they is there going to be any scrutiny
within the industry to keep them from
doing the crazy stuff that they were
doing is crazy
allowed that there definitely um 18
months ago was was quite a bit of
disarray at that company and um I
reached out at the time higher up of the
company had had them commit resources to
the state to go out and pick up tanks
they had lots of tanks that have been
sitting at customer locations for two
long periods of time uh they had
Workforce issues and and they had
management issues that they've addressed
and the number of of complaints has
dropped significantly and the tanks have
been picked up uh and they they actually
hired contractors to go out and assist
with their their own staff to get that
done so that that problem has been
resolved I have two very strong contacts
at a maragas that will take care of any
issue when I call with a customer issue
isue now and I am not calling in the
frequency that I was 18 months ago so I
believe that they're on a better path
forward um the propane business is
competitive so if you're not happy with
your your customer you can leave and we
have you know another 70 customers
companies to choose from pretty much in
the state um a lot of people have chosen
other companies and and gone with them
as as happens when you have poor
customer service so uh our role though
with with both of our associations is to
step in if there's any problem with the
propane in the state with a customer
complaint or constituent complaint
please reach out to us and we will we
will get it resolved for you because we
do not want want to be having any sort
of bad com customer service we want we
want to be safe and we want to make sure
that we're meeting our customer needs
and keeping them
warm representative Burrows yes thanks
for taking my question do you keep um um
statistics or tallies on how many of
these cases are favorably result off to
the to for the customers uh I handle
most of the calls myself and my my
office helps as well um we I think this
since this summer I've gotten two
complaints you know which is way down
from from what it was before I was
getting two complaints a week uh 18
months ago when when the problem with
the maragas happened before they came in
and and put resources in and resolve the
issue and you said two this summer two
I've had two since this summer okay
thank you
yeah just a drop obviously yeah so yeah
represent for two second thank you Mr
chair I have a like a consumer question
um I've been watching uh the price of uh
G uh propane natural gas uh On The Wall
Street Journal it keeps
dropping uh if I have a contract with
you for x
doar per whatever 500 what when I
exercise that
contract would I get the updated reduced
cost uh if I was you know I was quoted
six months ago I get it tomorrow do I
get the the reduced cost of today's
price or do I stay with the original
contract price so it depends what type
of contract you enter with them there's
different options that you have as a
customer some people pre- buby where
they come in and they say I'm going to
buy all of my product for the year I'm
going to buy it in the summertime the
the company actually goes out and buys
it on the Futures Market as well so
there's a little fee associated with
that but you get that low summertime
price there's also um cap prices so
what's most common in the industry is
your company will say I'm going to quote
you this amount of product that's the
cap that's the max it will go but if it
goes lower you'll get the lower price so
you'll get the price of the day so it
depends which contract you sign up with
with your your your company or if you
own your own tanks and you're just
calling and around in shopping price and
then having somebody come deliver
they're going to give you the price that
they can give you that day you know or
that delivery day when they come out and
deliver to you thank you I was just I
was just curious thank you very much the
more you use the lower the price because
we have to go out in an extremely
expensive truck and deliver it to your
driveway and and often in the winter
time and up a hill and there's ice and
everything else um so you know if if
it's if it's something the company can
schedule when they they're in that area
and they can make a larger Delivery drop
their costs for delivery are lower so
you're the more you use the lower your
cost great thank you thank you is there
anybody else who would like toh speak on
1395 seeing none we'll move on to the
next subject uh Senate Bill 9 seven rela
to the use of animals and product
testing yes it would
be so to be as brief as possible Kurt
aronberg for the Humane Society of the
United
States
97 FB Senate bill so this bill has been
around but what what happened and just
quickly to refresh refesh people's
memories if they have any memory of this
at the very end uh right before you had
to sign off on
bills uh uh the Humane Society in
Dartmouth College along with Senator
Waters and some of you uh rewrote the
bill to provide
for uh
biomed devices to be tested on when they
needed to be with animals the whole
concept of this bill is if there's a
better way to test
products in New Hampshire without using
animals we should use them that is what
this is about we agreed with Dartmouth
College that we would cover biomed
devices here and also that if a product
is approved for use with a biomed device
that does not mean that it would be
approved for another use that is not
biomedical so that language is in there
added in there as well that's what we're
asking what we're asking for is whatever
study is done recommend that the
language that we came up with is okay to
move forward in a new bill in the next
session that's the gist of why I'm here
today but isn't that already federal
law that you had that you're supposed to
try to find some other way to do it
before you no test an animal no it's not
we that's why we need to do it in the
States because there is no federal law
there's a p there my understanding right
now and is there is pending legislation
that is not ping okay not able to get
passed okay so we need to do it for the
animals New Hampshire and to set a
precedent that you know we don't want to
test on animals unnecessarily in New
Hampshire that's what this bill is about
and is there any testing going on in New
Hampshire at all well clearly there is
because outh college is interested in
this bill no they were just worried
about the language they were looking
looking at the way the bill was written
that there's a reason it's a reason
they're extremely interested in this and
that is because there's a potential for
it if not potential the fact that it's
going on now I don't know that okay fair
enough representative spear that was my
question because I remember at the at
the uh when we we met last time on this
bill we couldn't find any in inces where
the animals were being used for testing
currently in New Hampshire other than
what was going on at
Dartmouth and I I guess that's still
true
right okay well I just just to close
that we want to make sure it doesn't
happen ever I think we all would agree
on that right well I I have an
expression for that that I was taught by
Neil Kirk who was former chairman of the
finance committee and he calls that
prophylactic legisl
consider the
source thank you very much aren't dogs
and cats being
eaten ah yeah
right
right um but I am told it's still a
specialty there in in China Oh I thought
it was in Colorado no I no but that's
what they're saying is but I I always
thought it was
it's Chinese
delicacy okay uh moving right along so
does anybody have any other comments on
that bill thing okay moving right on
Senate Bill 365 relative to the sale of
use of lithium ion batteries for
electric bikes scooters or personal
Electric Mobility
devices great welcome I assume you're
from the Department
uh good morning Brian Allard uh
assistant director with the State Fire
Marshall's office Fire Marshall right um
good morning Marshall to me apologize he
wish he could be here today uh just to
make a few comments um our whole goal in
the fire Marshalls Office is to keep
people safe and try to mitigate any
fires uh by any means possible uh we
have over the last five years seen an
increase in uh lithium ion battery fires
and batter uh caused significant damages
to homes fortunately no loss of life as
of yet uh we think that having a
national or International uh thirdparty
and uh inspection of these batteries
prior to sale and labeling of those
would be prudent uh and uh keeping our
citizens of New Hampshire
safe okay representa
Pier what I remember from this bill when
we we talked about it last time was
trying to find the iso standard for
these kind of batteries and that was
what was missing for me is that I wanted
an international ISO standard did we
ever find one and I I think I even
listed one at the time uh thank you for
your question I know there was a
submission by a b people for bicycles uh
to the to this committee and they they
do list the uh the iso standard in there
is is that an update to the to the uh to
the bill or well I mean like again this
pill is in limbo land right now it's in
limbo but they they did Supply that
specific language is if anybody were to
put this bill back in again next year
that would be in there you want to make
sure that's in there absolutely okay and
we agree so um of the fires that we had
had any of those fires occurred by a a a
battery that uh wasn't certified
already so hard to tell right because
that the batteries are typically
destroyed so when we go in and do our
investigations you know we're asking the
homeowners the business owners kind of
what was in this area and try to narrow
down to that point of origin uh and
typically when we do find the batteries
they're totally destroyed so we can't
actually read if they are
labeled okay how do I ask this question
differently
um do you have any evidence that there
is a third-party battery that that's not
standard floating around in this
state sorry can you availability other
words said somebody could get a battery
I mean my experience when it comes to
batteries that especially with the bikes
because my wife sist getting one this
year is that the battery is designed so
can only fit theirs it's you know like
they almost have a patent on the way the
battery fits in and how it's done so I
guess I want to know is is are there
third you know when I say third party or
is there a non-manufactured approved
battery for any device around that
that's that have you ever seen any
evidence of one that did not have a
sticker have have have one of these
approvals on it there there are uh uh
times where there are unapproved
batteries being sold within the state so
those typically may have a higher
probability of not not being tested to a
certain standard obviously and those
have been shown not so much in our state
that we have evidence of but other
states uh that have caught
fire okay but you don't we don't have
any any evidence yet not conclusive that
that I could say here today correct okay
yes represent
spear like you we've gone out and bought
the electric bikes and if you're going
to spend $4 or $5,000 on an electric
bike you're going to get a nice battery
that goes with it but in looking at them
we found $800 bikes that had batteries
in them that you had no idea what those
batteries were the bikes were pretty
cheaply made and the batteries were
worse so they may not be third party
Replacements but I think there are bikes
being sold that are in I don't think
they belong on the road that that
they're pretty bad and like three $800
$400 you know I don't I think we maybe
need to do
something okay
represent thank you Mr chair thank you
for answering our questions just for my
own curiosity there are different size
batteries right so there are those
little battery packs that you get to
recharge your cell phone electric bikes
test those electric cars which category
of battery is the most problematic
that's my question uh great question
thank you for the question so in our so
we collect data from all fire
departments throughout the uh State
and there's not typically a drop down
specifically says lithium ion battery so
we have to do searches through their
narratives and through other parts of
the reports so the highest one um
happens to happens to be with u 8 p
are the are the highest ones and then we
go down to ebikes there's some hybrid
vehicles in there we're talking all of
all electric type batteries and then
kind of other category so forther
question me inquire thank you um I guess
this is what you believe there's a
disturbing video
online uh
Sur so it's uh it's three dogs alone at
home and they have a nanny cam on the
dogs and one of the dogs gets a hold of
one of these rechargeable battery packs
bites into it it catches on fire and
lights the whole living room on fire I I
don't know what happened to the dogs I
assume they got out safely but uh is
there a problem with uh you know if you
damage one of these does is it more
likely to catch on fire whether it's ice
ISO approved or not yeah thank you for
your question I have not seen that video
but I've seen others like that and yes
there is definitely a higher probability
if those battery packs are damaged um
that they can catch fire in some of
those videos you probably saw like a
huge uh what they call thermal runaway
kind of coming right out and it will
ignite a room and contents very
quickly and they stay on fire longer
right well don't airplanes you know the
airlines don't let you bring on those
skateboards or whatever the with the
batteries or the lithium battery I
believe that to be the case yeah and
they have they have so they so they just
don't they just ban it all together
right is that what they're yeah um I
guess I I feel compelled to say um years
ago uh I mean I'm probably unusual that
um we had these uh St Charles cabinets
built into our house which are steel
cabinets and uh they Pro is that they're
last forever real great and whatever the
company's now since gone out of business
but but to make a long story short um I
was reading an article that said watch
out for your 9V
battery because the 9vt battery has both
ends right next to each other and that
if you have metal drawers metal C and if
those battery gets connect touches it it
will
spark do we have any statue now that
regulates those batteries or 9vt
batteries or is it Federal does Federal
Regulation or anything exist now to uh
make sure those batteries are done
safely or packaged safely or what is
there anything on the books already uh
that that theory makes sense um but I'm
not sure if there's any uh regulation on
those on 9vt batteries yeah generally I
don't like to reinvent the wheel so if
that really was a problem I'd be
interested to know how how that got
resolved so but warning to everybody if
you have metal cab metal
drawers uh thank you Mr chairman does
this apply to other devices I've got a
number of household devices including a
a a charger that'll start my car that's
only this big uh I've got a electric
wheelbarrow um I a little nervous about
storing those in the house uh any advice
on how you store
those uh thank you thank you for your
question I can only give you my personal
what i t what I do for at home so I have
we battery op weed whacker and lawn
tools outside I had an old safe um and I
actually store them in there in my barn
I value my barn I don't want anything to
happen to it uh so I keep them in in the
safe so they're protected so if they do
have and watch out for that metal safe
don't let those ends touch it uh so I'm
hoping to you know limit my exposure and
keep that keep those in there so that's
what I do what I personally do at homes
I don't have a great answer for you but
that's
played golf with somebody this summer
who who had one of those remote control
golf golf Walker you know walk and walks
his bag around and need to say I'm sure
that had lithium batteries in it I'm
sure
did okay thank you very much thank you
sir uh and that is it on my list um all
right so now I want to go through the
list let's talk about from the members
of the committee which bills that uh
people would like to uh spend some more
time with so I know Keith you had a
bill yeah I I have two I'd like to
comment on but I don't know how much
time to spend on it if you want to well
I mean what I'm looking for is bills
that you want to
um uh have a subcommittee
on to a
sub this is my my my idea and maybe I'll
be overruled but it's 1232 all right and
okay and you would like to have
some uh a study committee that you know
spend some time working on these
issues uh I think it would be valuable
but like I said it's up to the the
committee and what whatever no it's
actually up to me oh it's up to you okay
people ask you why do I keep running for
the house and I said well you when
you're a chair it's it's pry chair the
chair decides whether you're gonna have
a subcommittee yeah chair the chair
decide appoints subcommittees the chair
and decide I I'm not talking no you know
you could decide whether we do it or not
do a subcommittee but in terms of the
actual vote on the bill when it comes
out of that that but yeah no the
chairman chairman appoints subcommittees
or decide whether it's going to be one
or not something to look forward to
huh so you're taking comments now I am
taking comments on these two bills which
ones I didn't even hear 1232 and 1674
and when I say committee I was using the
the Royal Wii yeah for the chair
yeah so and you're asking us for our
comments okay so next is once we once
I'm going to go forward and say yes so
now I'm interested in who would like to
be on this subcommittee so having two
subcommittees and you want to know I
think they they can be done at the same
time right they'll be scheduled at the
same time and in terms of when they get
scheduled uh that will be up to to Keith
to schedule them because I'm going to
point them chair this this is a comment
yes we've done 1232 now for two
years how much more studying are we
going to do on this and in that and in
addition to that some of us have read
5,000 pages of information from the
Federal Reserve indicating what their
plans are most of which are they're not
going to do
anything so talking about your
prophylactic
bills which I know are your
favorites how much more studying can we
do on something other than reading 5,000
Pages put your mic on and the ball is
now in your court so there there is uh
intervening
information um that we can talk about in
the in the subcommittee but I'll give
you one example okay so North
Carolina just passed the bill I'm
talking about
1232 very similar to 1232 they just
passed it the governor vetoed it they
overrode The veto so overwhelming
majority of the the North
Carolina legislature passed a very
similar bill in 1232 that's happened
since we talked about it so and that's
fine one example there's states that do
that states do all kinds of things
including this state have passed laws
that are very strange just because the
state passed the law doesn't mean
there's any validity to the fact that we
have to research it again I'll give you
another example if it's
okay the the American Bankers
Association issued a policy paper
opposing a central bank digital currency
that's happened since we and I read it I
read that and the situation that we have
there is that the Federal Reserve says
they are really not interested in
issuing such a currency that flat out
not interest now remember well I I I I
guess I want to intervene here all right
in my
mind even if we were to pass the law
we'll have no control over a federal
agency we don't okay so in my mind
forget about the Federal you know it it
it you know it says the way the bill is
written says prohibit state or local
okay we're not talking about Federal
here it is talking about whether we
would
allow either the state of New Hampshire
or a local
government to use a bank digital
currency so I'm sure that's what they
passed there and but look what you're
saying yes look what you're saying if
the Federal Reserve and they don't
intend to but if the Federal Reserve did
Issue a digital
currency that you would be prohibiting
people from this state for using it what
kind of a thing is that again this
legislation does not say make any
reference to Federal this legislation
simply says did you read the
bill uh do I have it in front of me no I
don't have it in front of me but all I'm
just reading from the title the title
says prohibit state or local read B I
don't see I don't see it saying Federal
read the bill okay so but you're can
still concern about Federal um I I my
concern in terms of state or local you
know to me this is what would your
interpretation this is prophylactic
legisl of course it is
okay to representative Spears point that
the FED currently says they will not
issue a digital currency
I would use the example of
History which is relative pardon me
relatively
recent uh in the Nicks Administration we
were on the gold standard until tell
midnight on Friday when we
weren't and we were on the same thing
can be said about the silver standard we
were on the silver standard until
midnight on Friday when we weren't they
do not give you
6 months 6 weeks or 6 hours of advanced
notice of change of
currency I think that this is absolutely
prophylactic uh
legislation I'm not sure whether it I'm
not sure how I feel about
it uh and I'm not sure I want to would
want to inflict a subcommittee on
somebody on it but I don't think it's
going to go away and I think it is a
relevant topic for this legislature to
consider either now or in the very
foreseeable
future um would the bankers Association
like to weigh in on this
one that is a no can you at least
support my statement that the American
Bankers Association came out against the
retail cbdc okay thank you okay that
isn't what happened I read it that is
not exactly what happened what happened
is they came the FED came out with a
list of questions 20 pages of questions
and the bankers Association came out
with their response to those 20 qu to
those 20 questions and in the in their
response they said well we don't like
this part of it we don't like that part
of it but we like this other part and
maybe this other part so it's not like
they said because the because the feds
have not come out with what it looks
like they don't know what it looks like
have made no decisions as to what it
looks like and in fact have said they
may not ever make it at at the retail
level where we would ever see it it may
be just bank to bank is one of the
things they were talking about so just
saying that they're against it that's
not exactly what happened at
all okay representative
Gibbs uh thank you um in reference to uh
whether this uh statute would have any
have any reference to any think Federal
doesn't Central Bank refer to the
Federal Reserve and in that case
wouldn't such a statute put state and
local governments in in conflict with an
agency of the federal
government I have a response for that I
I would have to look at the bill and see
what it had for
definitions comment please okay so um
obviously this bill needs a little more
discussion
I I get that there's opposition to
discussing it further but uh to
representative faxon's point this issue
isn't going away and this committee is
the subject matter committee for this
issue so we if we knew the conversation
going if we knew what it looked like
we'll zero in on that as they get closer
to that would be a good place to start
when you when you guys meet oh
God okay all right so we uh all right so
this one is 12:32
okay uh so we have representative
ammon's going to chair
it and representative spear is GNA be on
it okay who I do think good is CH Keith
is a good shamman so I'm okay with that
okay who else would like to be on this
this
conversation
okay uh and uh
anybody else we can go with
three technically I need a d another
Dem he's not a Democrat
I okay we'll go with those three that
assuming the uh ranking Democrat you're
okay with a subcommittee that's like
having down
yeah perfect okay all right next is
you actually what can we just put we'll
have the three no we won't start let's
just say that that do that too okay
so
okay you have any opposition do you have
any you have any campaigning to be doing
or never mind okay all right next bill
any other bills yes representative
Burrows um I'd like to pursue HB um 64
um relative to the resident-owned um I
just want the bill resident owned
manufactured housing part disputes um
I'm not sure that there's a legislative
fix for this but there seems at minimum
to be uh a lack of responsiveness in in
terms of uh the the agency or agencies
that are supposed to be um on top of
this so I I would like to explore um
what if anything could be done okay all
right who else would like to be on that
um I I'd be very interest interested in
that too and also HB
1645 let's just take one at a time well
I'm just saying I think that those two
go together which one um right above it
I I
think you could come up with some sort
of a board that would handle both
condominium and manufactured home uh
disputes a single board that could
handle both I think they're they're very
uh very connected so to
speak uh yeah they are I would agree
with
that so if we're going to have a
committee have a committee that that
does both and maybe can put it into one
bill okay so we do have someone who
would like to uh comment on this
please introduce
yourself good morning thank you so much
for taking my comment I'm Katie McQuade
with the New Hampshire Community Loan
Fund and um rock New Hampshire the resid
own communities organization um I'm also
a Manchester resident uh the I like what
uh representative is it melier yes is
saying about the Condominiums but we
also want to make sure that
investor-owned manufactured home parks
are included in this as well not just
resident-owned communities I think that
all of the if if this is going to be
studied all Park should be studied not
just the resident owned
funds makes sense to me thank you
for yes you want some share on this one
too I thought this was your nutty idea
to have both parks
good morning my name is Karen Susi I
work at she Infinity Capital group and I
represent the New Hampshire manufactured
housing Park Association so that
includes your manufacturers installers
and private park owners I think that
there's a significant difference in what
you're looking at um so you have
resident-owned communities that's the
residents own them not the private Parks
the Condominiums I believe there's also
some type of personal investment um on
behalf of the cond unit owners and so
you're having these disputes between the
boards and the residents in both
cases so I'm not support sure that you
would want to include privately
owned in
that okay um well I I would get to just
to referee this discussion that once you
create a subcommittee uh that
subcommittee is free to talk about
whatever they want to talk about
certainly I just wanted to make sure the
rest of the committee was informed as
well that that there is a disagreement
in terms of how broad this these two
bills should go correct can I ask
question everybody got
that I just want clarification so are
you suggesting that these not be
combined in one study group that
there're disparate issues I just want to
understand I well I think two things the
privately owned Parks wouldn't be part
of this because the residents don't own
have any investment in the park
themselves they don't own the
parks with regard to keeping them
separate I the condominium dispute
resolution and the uh resident owned I
don't have a position
okay um can I ask a question yes I don't
see why a privately owned manufactured
uh uh Park whatever
if a resident has a dispute why couldn't
that be bought to a a board that covers
disputes with with resident owned I I
don't understand the I understand the
difference in the ownership but I don't
understand the difference in why if
there is a a problem that you can't in
all cases go to a resolution
board so last I think it was last
session um they actually your legisl
uh got rid of the state manufactured
housing board because there were no
complaints that were brought within
their
jurisdiction but even then they they
didn't rule so much on up and down on it
they were just ruling in terms of
whether the person had a legitimate case
about what their complaint was no they
had fin out final word on what whether
there was a punishment or a final
decision ni a a premium increase no rent
was not included in that so the
complaints would be related to
Services um mostly I'm trying to
remember because there hasn't been one
in years um like whether or not a person
could have a sign on their house maybe
put up a flag rules it's about rules
yeah whether or not Park owners were
following their own park
rules that would it would be what would
be brought forward rul right
okay
so thank you what up all right thank you
so I again you know terms of I've been
around a long time so at one point in
time the issue was always about the
privately owned parks and the rates
getting increased and the people who who
are bound to be on that property because
they had their unit there that clearly
was not movable and that that they were
um upset about the premium increases and
they felt there was no control uh so we
did have legislation to uh have a board
to to get approval so that basically was
price controls over in increases of the
privately owned Parks um and I can tell
you I distinctly remember when that
occurred that the one thing that was not
included would be the community-owned
ones you know that uh because that the
theory was that they were just like
condos and when it comes to condos or it
comes to or the these Community own uh
residential Parks is uh that your your
rights are with the courts that you have
to take them to courts and that was uh
so that it would separate the issue um
so in terms of having that subcommitte
and having the subcommittee to help
understand everybody understand that uh
I realize it's very frustrating to think
that the only way you can get a resolve
is you have to go to Superior Court but
that is the way we have it New Hampshire
um and um so I I I don't have a problem
creating a this study committee and of
um discussing this problem and I think
representative buroughs you should share
it okay
okay anybody else
that's ma
Le
okay and I need a
republican demat dick you come on you're
a realer you
you well why do you have what's your
predisposed position on it
thank God your mic was off
okay can I just can you
[Laughter]
elaborate turn your mic
on uh well first of all what she I in
the process of teaching the real estate
class which I thankfully no longer do um
and we would go to the instructor's
Workshop over at the state before the
oplc dismantled the real estate
commission and we would have a
presentation by the manufactured housing
board lovely people they had no cases
nobody wanted to show up on the board
because there was nothing to do when you
got there uh
every 10 years or so there would be a
complaint so right there what she said
is correct Cor in my opinion the the
board and what I see this bill doing is
recreating a board that we just got rid
of and as a real estate
practitioner we're now going to have
to know about this utterly useless
board um I believe that in the case
of I'm not even hung over uh
this was it a tough primary huh yeah no
wasn't that bad uh
the all of these all of these entities
condominium
associations owned
Parks uh Cooperative
Parks all
have established
rules all of which are
easily more than most 99% of the time
are common ly enforced when you buy a
when you buy into a condo when you buy
when you buy into a a shared
Park they're required to give you 15
days to read the rules if you don't like
them you don't have to buy it so uh and
in the case of
owners you know I I do disagree with one
thing was said which is that in in in a
in a privately owned Park the residents
don't have a financial commitment
actually
in a privately owned Park the O probably
the only asset most of those people have
of any significance is the mobile home
that is in that Park but they understand
what they're getting into and there are
significant Protections in terms of you
can't evict them if you want to sell
your Park uh you
can't so there's there's lots of
protections already in in the law and
they're not hard to enforce certainly
that the homeowners association rule R
are not hard to
enforce um many residents wish they were
a little harder to enforce so for all of
those reasons I think that this is
utterly unnecessary legislation I think
it makes it harder for the people who
it's trying to protect to function in
their homes and their residences I don't
I don't see it I see it is solving a
problem for no one and creating a
problem for almost everyone that's can
can I just ask so if there let's just
say we have Bad actors in a manufactured
housing Park what is the resolution for
those people well so who's the who's the
bad actor is it the the board we say
it's the board the board the so the
elected board yeah and so and we kind of
heard that case where there's sort of
like this fascist dictator takeover of a
homeowners
association my personal take on that is
uh you need you need
to you need to if my answer to that is
first of all neither the former board
nor this board is really in a position
to handle that and secondly you have
judicial options you need to if if those
if the things that we heard testified to
here were really that
bad they should be going to the county
attorney okay and if the County Attorney
is unwilling to handle it they should be
going to elected representatives to get
the County Attorney to take it and if
that didn't work hire a lawyer to take
it on a contingency and Sue the beesa
all these people that's my answer I
realize that's a sophisticated no no I
think that's a good answer I just and I
I I like the idea about the county
attorney and the Reps um problem is if
you have to go the next step to an
attorney most of these people don't have
the funds to do that I understand that
but we're talking about a dozen people
and a small retainer on what's
essentially a easily winnable case okay
so I don't I don't think this is a
$50,000 retainer I think this is a you
know maybe a $2,000 retainer situation
okay thanks for that I appreciate it
yeah okay any Republican volunteers de
wasn't that
sub okay I I'll put myself on there
just all right so that's G to be Burrows
M Thaxton and hunt and Bros is the
chair okay next
oh back you had one no it oh you just
joining
this
okay all right represent spear did you
have something you want to take up on
terms of
these bills here tomorrow tomorrow's
list right okay all right so that's it
for this
list okay um I mean I know you know like
some like the um
P you know we've already addressed that
so we wouldn't want to be pass doing
anything there
um China the China there is a study
commit chapter study committee
yep and
uh
um I know in my grocery store doesn't
have the Disposable plastic put where
they they right they had a case when you
walk out then it's gone it's empty
now but I did see someone put in plastic
bags as a as a title got put in so we
will oh another bill
yeah just one
more can I make a comment yeah on that
1636 the Disposable L Hampshire
container deposit refund bill yeah
bottle bill yeah they're going to
rewrite it and submit it again
simplified down so we don't need it
now really working out well just like
marijuana works out really well there in
main right yeah yeah yeah it's good it's
good there's a lawsuit because the town
of Ky was I don't know if you be saw of
those we get the SE Coast News Don
kenary had a lottery that they raised uh
like $57,000 it was $775 the lottery so
you can get a store in K and they raised
$57,000 and then the person uh one
company was got won the lottery they
didn't qualify or they they they pulled
out or something so the next person on
the list it turns out they were too
close to a uh
school and so they're suing G for not
giving them a marijuana license
because because they near school and
because they near well just they said
they you know you took you accepted our
775 you or $750 you accepted the money
so you know that that was the onus was
on them to ensure that that their
proposal was legitimate and due
diligence not just take the
money so these study committees uh when
when do they have to have a result or
when are we supposed to be okay so
basically the the sub commes have to
meet and I usually you know it's in I
think these things are due I don't know
we have I grabbed a calendar
here they do out of commit we have
to
um
uh on
here where
was Last
oober okay yeah last dat of file yeah so
we have to have have to do this by
October
25th so obviously we don't want to go
you know drag this out till then we want
to get it solved sooner than
that okay first of all we I probably
would do it the week before in case
there is a
problem okay so so assume like a
Wednesday before so what I guess we can
look at that date
now and I really appreciate all of you
who showed up today this is really great
this is a great
turnout
16 okay so is
it octo um
16th 16th okay so we'll aim for October
16th to have our session we exact
session it'll come through the calendar
oh yeah yeah you'll get it but it and
and we'll exact all inter room study
bills okay just did you
explain any day
Bud
15th okay
okay
uh um we could do the 17
Thursday
okay filing the as in campaign Finance
filing uh don't you just have it on your
computer and you just print the that's
all I did is print my report because
it's all on my
computer okay
I realize for senatorial candidates you
guys have a much more elaborate
Financial filing than than us lowly
house
reps yes okay go ahead another bill yes
another bill I just wanted to comment on
a bill but not not offer it for study uh
1507 that's the uh the sandbox bill I
think I think that was Joe Sweeney's
bill so I I think that other states are
doing that and I think our issue was the
Regulator our regul didn't want it so if
they bring that bill back I just want to
comment that they should figure out and
that's your advice figure out who the
regulator the regulate right but other
states are doing that Financial sandbox
bill so that may come back that's the
only reason I'm commenting
right what are we doing what happened so
was was a A Whole New Concept you know
this is how I I fight dementias is new
ideas that I've never heard of before in
all my 38 years here was the sandbox and
that we're going to allow people to do
some financial
services and the banking and the
guidance of the banking Department
without the blessing of the
legislature
which anatha to me but um I guess I just
have to be more creative in my thoughts
you know in terms of in in when we did
the research for this one yeah just a
few months ago there were 11 states or
seven states that had tried it all of
them stopped all of them done did it the
only one who established anything was
Hawaii and they finished what they did
and no one has started it up again that
I could find as of about a month ago
well maybe things have changed who knows
but I'm Sor at any rate we'll hopefully
maybe that bill be all saying it may or
may not be introduced this next year
okay fine that's all I'm saying that's
all he's saying just
be no buckle your seat belts and be
ready for that next
year
okay our work is never done here okay uh
all right so um we created uh three well
technically four about three three study
committees so we have these two together
oh that's right so we have two that's
right that's right okay right because we
have that's right I did that wrong
didn't I okay all right so just to wrap
up we have a study committee with Ammon
Spear and
and meu in which um they will be
studying
uh 1232 and
1674 and then we have another study
committee that will be doing HB
1645 and Senate Bill 64 and that is
Burrows melier Thaxton and
Hunt okay could you explain the process
all right so basically uh the chair is
responsible to
schedule the meetings um in that you
know here it's a fre for all is a
subcommittee so you can talk about
whatever you want to talk about and our
work what's our work product and your
work product will be that um when we
come time to exec the bill uh which uh
the motion will still be not recommended
for future legislation but you will uh
write in the blurb oh that's right I'm
not supposed to say that the committee
report that you will write in the
committee report um that you were you
have have consensuses and that maybe
that there's a possibility that this
legislation go forward with what you
would think should be in in that
language we're recommending changes for
for someone who who would be interested
in reintroducing the bill can I yeah my
question my question is anybody can
introduce an LSR that's similar to the
bills that we're talking about right so
it doesn't prevent legislators from it
does not prevent reintroducing anything
anyways but it's just that it's just to
say that this committee has worked on it
had spent some time drilling down and
this is this is well that's maybe
support but this is where the things
they're going to say recommend you need
to resolve to come forward with that
bill that you need to think these issues
through and have a have an have a uh you
know an answer for these these problems
because we see these are are uh barriers
years for for passage it will come back
to this committee if we're studying more
than likely yeah I mean most the the
both both these issues are are that yeah
they're not going to really send them to
anybody else but us I mean Edna might do
a a dispute board but they might send
that to Edna but if it's if it says
condos manufactured housing it's got to
come here first and then go to Eda
second yes representative gibs and we're
looking to have an executive session on
October 17th correct thank
you yeah no 17th we move to the 17th
Thursday the
17th that the final meeting and that
would be the final meeting question yes
the subcommittees will they meet the
morning of and then we exec in the
afternoon or how's that going to work
could I would recommend they meet before
that date so we'll schedule sub
commmittee before the sub you want you
want to have the yeah you want to have
them long before that cuz you might want
to have another one okay you're not
you're not going to get it all solved
one
day that's
true it doesn't have to
Bean but I'm I'm really excited about
having so many of of you guys all coming
back because in in past years we've had
a a big turnover um and so this is great
that we'll have all this institutional
knowledge coming back so assuming all
win is this a plot on your part to keep
us from doing whatever campaigning we
need in order to win our
elections just ask
him uh you always have the opportunity
not to show up if you had an
important
flesh pressing the flesh
there's no uh there's no about having a
zoom to do
this
[Music]
uh man I I
yeah I wouldn't recommend Zoom because
you have a lot of body language a lot of
what people are
doing think maybe a preliminary
conversation if it's not complex I don't
think yeah I yeah yeah I would I might
I'm going to I want to say is I don't
recommend it okay I'm just saying like
with the bill I have I think that we may
have an answer that we going
toys
okay she's a chair of the committee so
she can do what she you you can call the
speaker and ask if you can do it by
Zoom I can call the speaker because
you're the
chair but I would not recommend it I I I
think sub committees work best when
people were right there looking at each
other eyeb eyeball and
yeah all right okay we are
adjourn I won't be here tomorrow yes
same time tomorrow I won't be here
tomorrow that's I'm G to go down to
Boston for